if you thought we had finally heard the
last of failed Arizona gubernatorial
Republican candidate Kerry Lake you were
wrong she is continuing to make all
sorts of outlandish claims about the
things she's going to do
to I guess try to steal an election she
lost to Katie Hobbs whose election win
has been certified and who listen very
carefully here
will be the governor of Arizona Katie
Hobbs will be the governor of Arizona
Kerry Lake will not be the governor of
Arizona because Katie Hobbs got more
votes and that's the way the system
works that's a good thing if the person
who got the fewest votes became the
governor that would be a real problem
Carrie Lake seems I guess to have found
an ally in Stephen Bannon and here is
Steve Bannon visibly struggling to cope
with Carrie Lake's loss and he he's
struggling so badly he starts making up
words if she had the receipts to show
that she was legitimate she would come
forth in and answer all this all they're
doing is obsficating obscating careful
careful careful
obsficating the reason is
they ain't got the receipts that's right
I understand that this election was
stolen let me underline that five times
stolen this really misunderstands burden
of proof and this is a real classic from
the right they did this with 2020 as
well well
we've got all these suspicious things
that happened prove Joe Biden really won
that's the wrong burden of proof Katie
Hobbs got more votes and won no one has
brought forward a bona fide legitimate
challenge to that why does Katie Hobbs
now need to do anything the election is
over the votes were counted Kerry Lake
and Steve Bannon and Trump and their
cronies haven't been able to demonstrate
that the person who won didn't really
win Katie Hobbs doesn't have to present
anything to them and this this is a
regular thing that they do uh flip the
burden of proof here's Carrie Lake now
defiant they're not going to keep
stealing elections well they haven't
stolen any any carry if they think they
can continue to steal and rig elections
they are messing with the wrong people
because they don't think that they
haven't done it they don't stand up
right now Steve and fight for this at
this moment I know people are tired but
this is the moment we need to get into
the fight right because if we if you
could let them rig another election it's
game over it's the country's let's not
let them rig any more elections I mean
they haven't rigged any so that's a good
track record and let's make sure that
they don't start these folks are
completely delusional here's just one
more clip just it's it's it's copium my
friends I mean Kerry Lake who is let me
be blunt
when you look at the analysis you look
at the data you look at this lawsuit is
the governor elect of Arizona she is not
the governor-elect of Arizona she lost
do you think Steve Bannon believes this
crap for a second I have a really hard
time believing that he does she there's
just no doubt she won this election okay
and they've circled the wagons to
protect Katie Hobbs and this is going to
be a battle royale because if there's
going to be no battle the election's
been certified for Katie hubs Katie
Hobbs will be the governor there will
there's no battle other than in their
minds you're if you're in for a penny
you've got to be in for a pound here on
this fight right and the fight is in
Arizona and the fight is in Arizona
today yeah there's no fight I mean yes
they are submitting what they claim to
be legal complaints and maybe some
qualify as legal complaints there is no
fight in so far as Katie Hobbs will be
sworn I mean I hate to even say it
unless she's dead Katie Hobbs will be
sworn in as the governor
and that's it
that's the end of it before you go if
you enjoyed this video and want to see
more please make sure to subscribe to my
YouTube channel you can click the
Subscribe button below or above or
wherever it is on your screen and if you
want to support my work even more
strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description